ed O'Keefe by the way has been in New
Hampshire covering the race for the past
week and he's at a polling station in
Bedford that's just outside of where I
am in Manchester ed good morning what
can we expect to see in the primary
today well as Secretary God had told you
we would expect results faster than we
did in Iowa and God bless them hundreds
of people already here in line they vote
for sport here in New Hampshire but only
about 39 percent of voters tell us
they've actually made up their minds so
many of these people may have shown up
undecided this morning
if turnout is big that likely benefits
senator Bernie Sanders given that he s
the largest base of support but don't be
surprised if it also helps Mayor Budaj
edge who of course came out of Iowa with
a win or even senator Klobuchar who you
mentioned has had a good few days let's
win this thing
let's transform America New Hampshire I
believe you will help make me the next
president of the United States New
Hampshire's top two candidates pulled in
some high-profile surrogates for
last-minute help the strokes and
congresswoman Alexandria lo Cascio
Cortes rallied for senator Bernie
Sanders in every poll Bernie beats Trump
while kevin costner offered his support
to former mayor people to judge but
throughout the day both buddha judge and
sanders kept attacking each other
picture where your only choices are
between a revolution or the status quo
is a picture where most of us don't see
ourselves
my friend missed the Buddha judge or my
friend Joe Biden they have dozens and
dozens of billionaires contributing to
their campaign New Hampshire primaries
are open to independent voters who
account for roughly four in ten ballots
cast and many voters this year say it's
been hard to make a choice we're down to
you know maybe a half a dozen people who
seriously have a shot at it it's working
it's working it's messy but in their
urgent play to meet as many of those
undecided voters as possible candidates
added extra events throughout the day
and made their final pitches I know some
people say experience doesn't matter
well I think it does it's the reason why
I'm running after the debacle in Iowa
some candidates say they would have
spent more resources in New Hampshire
well certainly I think if you had a
crystal ball and perfect information
given what happened in Iowa you probably
would invest differently but the
surprise contender of the last 48 hours
who's surging in some polls to third
place is senator Amy Klobuchar some
people are calling this clone mentum
we're saying that you are now closed
lovely names I don't care just so they
vote for me a reminder that today is all
about delegates eventually a candidate
needs 1990 of them at least to win the
Democratic nomination tonight New
Hampshire awards 24 of its delegates
ultimately it has 33 to the convention
and a candidate needs to win at least
15% of the vote to win a delegate Tony
and at every delegate counts it's
whether criss-crossing this state thank
you very much